how are you feeling about aging I'm not
doing well with it nobody does well with
it no how's your health do you feel
robust from that end of it I feel
perfectly fine I mean I feel no
different I could jump on stage now and
do do the show you know but um it's I
don't know I mean hey it's it's a
process right you don't you never grow
up no you know I mean it's a fact you
know you get to a certain St you're
growing down you know I'm waiting for
the diapers yeah
was rehab harder or smoke quit one well
right quitting smoking actually I found
the quitting smoking fairly easy really
yeah yeah uh it was just something that
said inside that said now you you got it
yeah and you know you got that inner
force that
says okay you know I mean this is no
[__] foot in uh you got to and uh
comparatively easy far easier than boo
right really
yeah